brad we got this comment the other day
on our youtube channel
and it said everybody should be paid for
their labor
this is especially true in the film
industry paying your dues
quote unquote is a manipulation tactic
used to exploit newcomers
working for free is a good way to commit
career suicide
it will get you labeled as an amateur
and shunned by unions
okay what's your reaction to that but
you know i
i know people who who have that opinion
the dilemma in the film business as
competitive
as it is is where is the incentive
for an employer in a market that is
overcrowded with experienced people
to pay an inexperienced person that's
the dilemma and
you know i i'm aligned with the ideology
of that statement i think it's a fair
concept yeah but practically you know
this is
a business that because of the
competition
you know people are gonna do what they
have to do
to jump ahead and and a quick way that i
know for people to get experience
and build up their resume is to you know
volunteer and work on jobs
and you can certainly do that with your
peers and students
you know but what are you going to learn
from them you know how much
knowledge do they have to pass on how
impressive is that credit
gonna be you know i can only speak for
myself but if i was in that position
and i was when i started out my first
job was a freebie i worked on a
on a passion project for some people in
houston
and you know they were professional
filmmakers so i would go
out on you know the odd days that they
were shooting
and i would volunteer and and but i was
learning from very experienced people
i had the opportunity to impress those
people um
and uh you know so that some of those
people are still
friends and i work with them to this day
um likewise on some of my
shoots with you know i support my
friends if a friend of mine says i have
a little short i want to make or i want
to do a spec
project you know of course i'm going to
come you know help you and
even if they offer to pay me i i don't
like doing that i don't like charging my
friends
for personal projects if it's a
commercial project you know by all means
cut me in
um and on things like that for crews i i
typically
you know talk to students and mentees of
mine and i say hey you want to
you want to come out and the reality is
that i've had a lot of people
i've done this you know 20 or 30 years
and they come out and
and you know the exceptional ones really
bust their butts
and and you know they learn and they pay
attention
and they impress everybody and at the
end of the day
people are getting their name and their
numbers and you know somebody calls me
and says do you know a sharp pa we're
hiring
and i'm like yeah this person did a
great job so
practically i find that you know
a mechanism that works and if somebody
has a better mechanism if they have a
mechanism by which an inexperienced
person
can get hired and paid over
all the inexperienced people or all the
experienced people
who are sitting around with nothing to
do waiting for that call
i'd love to hear it but but to me that's
the dilemma
right and i i you know no no disrespect
to whoever left this comment and i get
what they're saying in the sense that
especially if you don't come from a
situation where you can take time off
and do free work not everybody does and
i can respect that that's
that's a big factor in a lot of this um
that you would feel maybe that okay i
might be being used here if i keep
showing up at what point should someone
say okay i've done enough free work
or is there never that point well
it's not about doing or not doing free
work it's about doing it strategically
i'm 30 years into my career i still do
it
for my friends for clients who pay me
and say hey i have a spec spot but i
don't have any money
sure you know i support you know people
this is
a business where we scratch each other's
back you know it's a question of you
know
are you being taken advantage of is
somebody being predatory
um to me that's that's the thing that
you have to look at
and i would say to somebody who's like
oh and the other thing i wanted to
mention too because you're saying they
can't afford
to do a free job um you know having a
conversation just the other day with
somebody
that the film industry is a business
it's a business like any business
your time is a commodity and if you have
a business you have to invest in that
business
you know part of that is you know paying
union dues paying for head shots
um you know giving your agent 10 i mean
you know the professional organizations
and and some of it is the commodity of
your time
you know if i have an opportunity to
work with a director i really want to
work with
um because they're doing a a film
competition and i have nothing else to
do to me i'm investing in the potential
of building a relationship that's going
to carry on to paying work that's my
intention
now if they keep calling me for freebies
i'm going to be like well
you know that that well has run dry and
for a new person
you ask when do you stop doing freebies
well i would counter by saying
if you're doing nothing but freebies and
not getting called for paying work
you need to look at two things one are
you doing freebies with amateurs and
people who have no connections
or two are you maybe not doing a good
job because if you are working with
experienced people and you're busting
your ass
there's a good chance that you're going
to be getting called for work and you're
going to be getting referrals
there's exceptions to every rule so you
know
but but i would just say by and large
what i have seen
in my years of mentoring people and also
you know again i feel if somebody comes
and donates their time on my project i
owe them something
and that something is if they do a good
job
i'm gonna i'll give them advice i'll
mentor them
i will look out for opportunities for
them i will try and bring them on paying
jobs i will recommend them
you know but conversely if they come
come and they show up and they
and they don't bring it and they don't
do a good job and they don't pay
attention i mean
i appreciate that they tried but i can't
in good conscience send that person to
one of my paying clients
because that's going to reflect on me
that's another thing too is people
always need to remember
that if somebody ever recommends you
they're putting their reputation on the
line so
it's not just you know if you get
recommended you don't show up and do a
good job just for yourself
you do a good job for that person who
recommended you because if you do a
crappy job
the next time that person wants to make
a recommendation the person is going to
say no that
that last last person you sent me wasn't
so good
and so somebody you don't even know is
going to miss out on an opportunity
because you set a bad precedent
do you think it's a generational thing
do you think maybe in the 90s
there were less interns or this is
always how the film industries worked
you know honestly i think it's it's
always how people have worked
there's there's so many stories you know
probably back into the era of silent
films of people sneaking on set
and and somebody just mistook them for a
crew person and put them to work and
and somebody's like you know eventually
they got paid um
uh you know it's an unorthodox business
and
uh just by intrinsically it's an
unorthodox business now
the perception from people from the
outside is that we're all on holiday you
know i have relatives who think i sit by
the pool
and drink frozen drinks with you know
models fanning me
every day that i'm not on set which
isn't true i work harder on those days
you know networking and hustling but um
it's a business and a lot of young
people don't get that they think oh i'm
an artist
you know which i get because i consider
myself an artist too
but the rude awakening is that there's a
lot of business in this
um but because it's an unorthodox
business
for instance you know i could show up on
work in in a t-shirt and jeans
you know you can't wear flip-flops
because they're unsafe
but but there's not a quote-unquote
dress code although
humorously and anecdotally i'll tell you
there kind of is because no matter where
you go in the world
a grip looks like a grip and a director
looks like a director
i don't know what it is man because i
didn't get that memo but i think it's
very funny
um but but you know it's it's an
unconventional business and i think
creativity and originality and
unconventional thinking
is is rewarded and celebrated you know
just like when spielberg
you know went and squatted an office on
on the studio backlot you
probably know that story um and uh
you know for instance with resumes
people do resumes if people ever give me
a resume that looks like a corporate
resume i say man
it's really wrong and we we talk about
the points and
you know one of the fundamental points
is that this is a creative business
you know get creative do an interesting
font a creative layout some color
somebody gave me
uh advice once which i thought was
brilliant advice i was i was talking to
them i had a meeting
and you know i was uh talking about you
know how should i present this thing and
they said brad
this is show business put on a show
and i to me that is like an overarching
defining
qualification of almost everything i do
be it a resume
or a website or a meeting you know
and putting on a show involves
preparation it involves
you know intention it involves
follow-through it involves
thinking on your feet while it's
happening um
and i'm diverging a little bit but the
point that i'm getting back to
is that is that it's it's it's always
held its appeal it's
it's always kind of like you know
running off to join the circus
um i think you know there's a certain
kind of people it especially
appeals to and these are you know people
who are in in life maybe the
outcasts or the artists or the fringe
people or
you know they think differently they see
the world differently
and that's a valuable asset in this
business
and again you know i had a uh one of my
mentees once is a script supervisor
and which she was starting out you know
she got an imdb pro account
and she's uh you know very attractive
young lady and she said
i i'm a little bit of verse to put my
photo up because
you know it kind of looks like a model
and i don't want to give the wrong
impression and i said to her this is a
business
where whatever whatever advantage you
have you play it
you know if you if you qualify for a
diversity program
you know by your gender or your
ethnicity if
you like me you've just got years of
experience um
you know with her she's an excellent
script supervisor and that's fine
but you know what if somebody hires her
because she's got
a cute photo on imdb pro you know
as long as they don't abuse and harass
her you know if that pushes her
ahead of the competition and gives her
the edge i say
you know anything that is honest and has
integrity
um you know you don't want to cheat and
be deceptive or abusive to anybody
but whatever your edge is and everybody
has a different edge i mean
i could have a meeting with a producer
and i've done my due diligence and i'm
like they like to ride horses so
i'm gonna play that up i'm gonna play i
like horses i love horses i've ridden
horses
and if that's my advantage so be it um
but anyway i'm sorry i believe i strayed
quite quite a bit from your question
no i love it i love it i love when when
it's sort of a circuitous
it goes back to our original point so
yeah probably going back to vaudeville
and yeah the silent
you know people have been volunteering
and then hey you're hired you know but
people ran away from home for that stuff
there was no
you know there was no expectation of
remuneration it was like
you know i'm gonna go join the circus um
and you know some of those people had
really hard lives i mean some of the
people did they have hard lives i've had
some hard weeks and months you know it's
it goes around but um yeah it's a
business where
you know again that whole thing i was
talking about in terms of creativity
and originality i mean that's not
necessarily in your visual expressions
that's also in your strategy you know
again spielberg and his
office squatting or um you know
i go and i speak to college students and
you know two or three come up after
class and say i'd like to
intern i'd like to volunteer you know
those are the guys who who
get invited and sorry what is that
spielberg story i'm not sure i know that
one
sorry well i
i wish i knew it a little bit better but
but basically
um he
was able to get on the lot and he just
found an empty office and
set up shop and and it's it's i'm sure
the details are really good but i i
don't have them fresh in my mind it's a
legendary story but that was kind of how
he got his launch
before he got his first opportunity
which i believe was a night gallery
episode
with joan crawford it's the one where
she plays a blind lady
um it's a great episode i i wish i could
tell you the the kicker it's got a
little you know twilight zone-esque
uh twist but anybody who wants to see it
i'm not gonna spoil it for him
um but you know it's just it's just that
out of the box thinking you know he
thought of it
and you know 300 of his classmates
didn't and whereas he and where are they
you know and that's just an example and
it
can manifest in so many different ways
just like you know just like the
students i mean
one of the things when i'm speaking to
classes that i'm always tempted to do
and i kind of don't because it's a
little cruel but is to tell people you
know look to your left
look to your right in five years those
persons
those people are not going to be in the
business not meeting those specific
people but as a generalization you find
that there's tremendous attrition
for a variety of reasons you know um but
it's it's you know people just
it's you know it's it's a an industry
where
staying in the game and pushing forward
in and of itself is an advantage
you know but you just you just always
want that that thing you know to be able
to
you know what can i do that nobody else
is doing because if all you're doing
is what everybody else is doing then
then
you might as well be a penguin and a
pack of penguins on an iceberg in
antarctica
you know you want to be that penguin you
know with the red bow tie that's jumping
up and down and doing funny stunts
because all eyes go there
you know and and that's even true on set
you know just like i said
um i always notice when there's that one
pa that oh you know something needs to
be swept up
zip you know oh they need help moving
something zip
can you go wrangle the background zip
and i'm talking about a real person
there's one person that specifically
that that story comes from
you know but i've seen other people do
it but it's like you know that's you
know
johnny on the spot person who shows up
before anybody else person who leaves
after everybody else
very simple things you know and they
have nothing to do with
you know what you actually may know
whether you can
tighten a c stand or or fill out a uh
deal memo but it's that attitude it's
that mentality
um and and you know again that's just a
different manifestation of it or
if you have that resume that's just got
that super cute
font and it's laid out in a way that
i've never seen before i'm like wow
i'm gonna remember that person so put on
a show
you